activision has provided an update for
next year's call of duty battlefield has
refreshed one of its launch maps and the
ps plus games for august are now live
in a statement during its q2 2022
earnings report activision said quote
across the call of duty ecosystem the
teams are well positioned to support
these launches with substantial live
operations while also continuing
development of new premium content
planned for 2023 and beyond but devante
what does that mean well over on twitter
bloomberg's jason schreyer said quote
for 2023 i'd expect new paid premium
content for modern warfare 2 not a brand
new call of duty treyarch is leading the
next mainline game which was delayed to
2024 as bloomberg reported earlier this
year this reported delay would be the
first time since 2004 that a year would
pass without a new mainline call of duty
game which has had an annual release
schedule since 2005's call of duty 2.
call of duty modern warfare 2 is
scheduled to launch on october 28th and
will likely increase engagement in the
series if all goes according to plan the
proposed activision blizzard acquisition
by microsoft is also expected to be
finalized next year after it's approved
by various government regulatory bodies
across the world over in brazil newly
published documents by the country's
business watchdog group has revealed
that sony believes microsoft's ownership
of call of duty could persuade users to
switch to xbox in the future and as i
mentioned in yesterday's edition of
gamespot news the funny thing about this
is that playstation has been using call
of duty to influence player choice for
years now by having exclusive and or
early access to content for example
2019's modern warfare launched with a
co-op spec ops survival mode as a ps4
exclusive feature but speaking of
playstation don't forget to grab the
free games for august today available
now are tony hawk's pro skater oneplus 2
yakuza like a dragon and little
nightmares pro skater oneplus 2 is a
remake of the first two classic tony
hawk pro skater games and the collection
used the dna of those titles to form a
new skateboarding experience that looked
great and played even better with some
clever tweaks to the formula yakuza like
a dragon was a major departure for the
franchise as it started a brand new
protagonist and flipped the action from
street brawling to rpg inspired
turn-based combat as for little
nightmares this 2017 game earned
favorable reviews for its eerie
atmosphere imaginative style and tense
gameplay sequences you have until
september 6 to add them to your library
but why wait start living your pro
skater dreams right now also available
today is an update for battlefield 2042
version 1.2 of the game includes bug
fixes balance changes and quality of
life improvements one of the biggest
parts of this update is the first of
dice's planned reworks for 2042's launch
maps this one is kaleidoscope and
according to the patch notes the map now
features improved gameplay flow with new
cover assets flag positions terrain
elevations and visual changes update 1.2
also introduces the game's new revised
art direction for its specialists in
order to help them feel more a part of
the gritty 2042 game world other changes
include a player profile and statistics
page
aim assist on controllers feeling
smoother and more consistent and a
couple weapons have been tweaked but
alright if you made it this far hit the
comment section and leave the word
butter or the butter emoji then like
this video if you haven't and i'll see
you tomorrow
[Music]